it's great to be here in Tokyo to start
my trip to Japan and the first stop is
the Costco Naval Base where we are now
that's because we're announcing a new
defense partnership with Japan today and
the closer cooperation between our Armed
Forces our cyber agencies and indeed our
semiconductor companies and researchers
will all strengthen our security at home
after this I'm heading to meet Japanese
Business Leaders who are announcing 18
billion pounds worth of new investment
into the UK that's going to support and
create jobs and I'm looking forward to
having dinner with prime minister
kashida tonight reflecting on the modern
partnership between our two countries
that is delivering real benefits for
people at home